[Music]
hi there Jenny here I'm a sales trainer
for Google cloud and I'm Heather good to
have you back Jenny so today we're gonna
be talking about the Internet of Things
or IOT it sounds pretty generic if
you're unfamiliar with this term but
we're surrounded by this technology
every day that's right so on this
episode we look at Google cloud IOT core
a managed service to help securely
connect and manage IOT devices at scale
make sure to stick around for our quick
demo of the self-paced lab on cloud IOT
core put simply IOT is taking devices
that were not traditionally connected to
the Internet and then adding Internet
connectivity to them why because data is
being created all the time from devices
applications and their users by adding
connectivity a wealth of data that was
traditionally offline becomes actionable
cloud IOT core is a fully managed
service that allows you to easily and
securely connect manage and ingest data
from up to millions of globally
dispersed IOT devices the services
serverless and it doesn't require any
upfront software installation it also
scales instantly with the horizontal
scaling of Google cloud platform cloud
IOT core provides a way of creating a
registry where you can define where
devices are and then connect them device
telemetry data is forwarded to a cloud
pub/sub topic you can then use cloud
functions to trigger API calls or you
can use dataflow to extract that data
from pub/sub and put it into a data
warehouse such as big table or bigquery
this will allow you to analyze and react
to that data in real time
so let's jump in a quick laps you can
check out the link to start the quick
lab here you'll need to set aside about
40 minutes to complete it this hands-on
lab will show you how to use Google
cloud platform console to create a cloud
IOT core device registry connect a
device and publish device telemetry
events so far in the lab we've created a
device registry with a cloud pub/sub
topic for publishing device telemetry
events we then added a device to the
registry and added a public key to the
device so that it can connect to GCP we
did some setup to run a node.js sample
to connect a virtual device and view
telemetry once at this stage we'll run
this command in cloud shell to create a
subscription to the registries pub
subtopic then we run this command to
connect a virtual device to cloud IOT
core using the MQTT bridge the output
shows that the sample device is
publishing messages to the telemetry
topic 25 messages are published
finally we run this command to read the
messages publish to the telemetry topic
we created a cloud IOT core device
registry connected to device and publish
device telemetry events we hope you
enjoyed this episode as much as we did
and don't forget GCP offers a 12 month
free trial with $300 in credits so you
can apply what you've learned today and
start using it with your data in
addition there are resources for you to
take advantage of to learn even more
about cloud technology and GCP check out
all the links in the description below
thanks again for watching and we'll see
you soon